foreign
is in Des Moines Iowa how are you Andrea
I'm great thank you so much for taking
my call David George sure what's up
so my question is we're in baby step
seven and I was wondering if it's okay
or if it's violating the principles to
get go back into debt for a mortgage to
get a bigger house
so the situation is I've started working
again our hustle income went up seventy
thousand dollars so we're at about two
hundred thousand dollars
annual income we have a net worth of
about eight hundred thousand dollars and
are more are not our mortgage our
primary residents our only resident is
worth 350 about and we have a over
emergency fund about a hundred thousand
dollars in savings and you want to move
from 350 to what
to about 750 or 800
and
um our current house is like 1300 square
feet plus 1100 square feet finished
basement and we have five kids
okay
um well there's not a uh a principal in
the Ramsey process or baby steps that
prevent you from doing that as long as
the payment's no more than a fourth of
your take-home pay
all right on a 15-year fixed
um
I gotta share with you the truth though
I mean you make 200 000 a year sure you
have a hundred thousand dollars saved
you have 350 so that's 450.
um 550 650 750 you can do this in three
years if you just save it
and um okay I I personally you know you
delay investing for that to save it
um
I mean you have an 800 000 net worth at
what age
41. yeah you can if you want I I would
have to figure it out because I don't
borrow money and it would be
particularly hard
for me to go back into debt once I had
received personally it's just a personal
observation not a not a sin not not a
discussion of the baby steps or the
principles the principles are you can go
do it as long as you do it on 15 year
but I just couldn't do it emotionally
I just couldn't put myself back in there
I I I I I value my freedom more than I
do my style of living
standard of living
yeah that's where we're at my husband is
on team what would Dave do and I'm on
team Dave wouldn't yell at me yeah well
Dave's not going to yell Dave's not
gonna yell at either one of you you're
rock stars I mean you're amazing oh you
can't say rock stars anymore after the
commercials but yeah but anyway you're
amazing you're fabulous and and you've
done a great job you've got a you know
approaching a million dollar net worth
you're making 200 000 a year you got
five kids everything's paid for there's
no Dave yell at you anywhere
but I just gotta I would be sad because
I just couldn't do it emotionally
gotcha I just it would just it makes my
stomach hurt a little bit thinking about
it and that mortgage would be we're
talking a 400 000 mortgage so that's
that's sizable that's more than the
house is worth they put down 400 after
fees wait until spring maybe 300 but
still and but then you could pay it off
in three years that would be the goal if
they did this move it would be how fast
can we pay this off yeah to get better
you know 100 000 a year because you just
increase your household income by 70 the
other day so I think you could put 100 a
year on this and probably still do
investing but I I would have to and if
you were saving to buy how deep would
you sacrifice to save up to pay cash so
that you could do it in two and a half
years rather than four and a half years
you know if you just put a little
thermometer or savings thermometer on
the refrigerator and you colored it in
right made it a big goal how fast could
we get there because that's honestly how
we do everything
we can't do it until we can see how we
can pay for it because we don't borrow
money because I just
can't go back
to having anything in my mailbox or my
inbox that looks like a bank no more
payments I just can't do it I just life
is too good I've been free for too long
I mean it's a little bit of slavery okay
would you yell at me for some slavery no
I'm not gonna yell at you but I'll be
sad
for your slavery well once you live
without that payment I mean it's it's
not what would Dave do that's not the
point it's not me I mean it's you know
why did you do all this work to get to
here
and then when I go back
after you got here I just it feels like
or it feels like we're you know you know
I lost 600 pounds is it okay to eat a
box of donuts yeah but probably not
gonna give you what you thought it was
going to give you you know
and it's just um probably not gonna feel
good when you finish you're probably
gonna wake up with like a sugar hangover
a little regret yeah it could happen
you know I haven't I haven't had a drink
in 10 years I used to be an alcoholic
but I think I'm gonna try some bourbon
tonight you know I mean I just don't get
it it's okay
dangerous
I don't I don't know if those metaphors
play or not I'm sorry for you people in
the addiction field but yeah oh my gosh
yeah but there's something there I just
um and it's
y'all don't need my permission out there
or George's permission to do stuff we're
just trying to give you principles and
guidelines that are your shortest best
route to a great life of wealth and
prosperity we want you to be there and
we want you to stay there when you get
there so I don't know I'm
but yeah technically we don't tell
people
um if you wanted to go upgrade the house
and take on a people do it all the time
they do it all the time and then they
turn around but I gotta tell you you're
probably gonna hate it so much you're
probably gonna go bananas and pay it off
really really fast
because it's probably going to drive you
drive you which again if you stay there
with five kids you're going to want to
save up really fast to go we gotta
upgrade this thing so either way it's
it's gonna happen yeah I think that's
the that's the way we do it is it in
either what happens is we either get
increasingly motivated and cut deeper
and deeper and deeper and deeper to get
to things sooner or to get to that goal
sooner or we um
or we get decreasingly motivated and we
realize we didn't want it and we
abandoned the goal one of the two the
last time we did this that I can
remember where we cut at the Ramsey
Place really really really deep uh was
about
gosh I'm trying to think it's probably
15 years ago when we bought what is
financial peace Plaza oh yeah our old
headquarters our old headquarters and I
bought that building for five million
dollars and it was the first time I had
bought something that expensive and
there was a timeline to that right yeah
and I had I had to had to close it by a
certain date I had an option on it and
if I didn't close it by that date I was
not going to get it and by the time the
date was up the building was worth 13
million and I had it tied up at five wow
so I had eight million dollars on the
table that's some incentive that I was
going to walk away from if I didn't come
up with the money but I wasn't willing
to borrow it man we we scratched every
nickel out of the corner of the couch we
turned couches upside down and shook
them you did a GoFundMe before it wasn't
cool we did everything and we barely
closed on that building but it was but I
would have walked before I went into
debt I would have walked away from it
you're crazy Ramsay